hey girl yeah Walk This Way with that
fine ass so flip yeah girl why don't you
come down here and put that in my mouth
cause daddy want a snack black why you
hurting me girl
that's deliciousness yeah yeah
yeah keep it coming yeah
and and that is a professional
basketball mascot that is a man and an
orange rhinoceros costume
hell off that rhino
[Music]
what can I say about ancestry.com my
adventure began when I received a leaf
pointing me in the direction of my
great-grandfather who was a pilot with
the flying aces in World War One on my
mother's side I found an aunt who traced
her lineage all the way back to Thomas
Jefferson
I was able to trace my bloodline back to
Nobles and even a king I discovered I'm
a direct descendant of Eric the Red
after only a couple of hours on
ancestry.com I was able to trace my
family line all the way back to none
other than our third president
Thomas Jefferson Marie Antoinette Thomas
Jefferson
Aristotle Thomas Jefferson Alexander the
Great Thomas [ __ ] Jefferson
join ancestry.com and begin a
one-of-a-kind journey into your unique
past because you never know where your
Story begins
all right you're doing fine sweetie
now I'm Malia let's just go easy on the
gas here and come to a complete stop
so in the future you want to try not to
go through stop sign
okay just remain calm now and what
you're going to want to do is pull up
right here next to the curb
this is why we want to stay in the lines
when we want to follow rules
remember this
license and registration
oh holy Mr President yeah yeah just uh
teaching Malia to drive well you guys
ran a stop sign back there but that's
okay you can go oh no no no no no
Malia's got to learn what it's like to
drive in the real world here well this
is called consequences Malia now I want
you to go ahead and treat us like you
would if I weren't the president
not exactly what I had in mind hey all I
know is it's good having another brother
move into the neighborhood hey man it's
good to have you over and I think that
you will dig this
um
hey
nice guitar collection oh thanks Manny
you want to hear something
yeah sure all right all right
well I'm just a good old American boy
with a heart that's red and true
dreaming of the girl with the red hair
and freckles in her eyes like the skies
of blue country music yeah I grew up in
Texas you know so all right keep her
safe from the homies in the wrong side
of town where they're smoking the reefer
and acting like clowns
that pretty wide dress from getting
dirty and brown cause that's the
American way
oh
pretty racist song
racist against who
of black people black people but I'm
black
well keeping the red-headed girl away
from the homies on the wrong side of
town homies come on brother there's all
kinds of homies you know you white
homies Asian homies
no homies are black no I think you're
making them black man I mean I think
that's your stuff you hear the twang
and then you assume that it's racist but
that's that's just what country music is
like here look you're gonna like this
one you'll like this one all right
some folks wear their hats way off to
the side with their pants down low and a
gun tucked inside take the rear by the
40 and their chicken deep fried I think
we all know who we're talking about
the only dark I like is when I turn off
the lights the only Hood I love is
pointy and white tan trust you if I can
see your face at night I think we all
know
wait wait hey stop that
that's racist what's what what is racist
about it the only Hood I love is pointy
and white yeah man
let's talk about the clan man
the Ku Klux Klan
are you outside of your mind that's
traditional country music imagery man
like a pickup truck or sleeping under
the stars or your dog got killed or your
wife left you same thing I would have
been fine with any of those things what
is the difference between those things
and what is in the song they're not
racial hey you know I can't just say
something man I'm just gonna be frank
you're getting a little like Al Sharpton
like um Farrakhan on me right now oh my
God are you serious dude hey give me you
know can I do one more let me just do
one more dog I absolutely promise you
that this song is not racist and it's
impossible for you to misinterpret it as
such
okay it seems like you're about to sing
the most racist song so far
get me a rope and find me a tree okay
foreign
come on man hey
sing about a tire swing
right off an entire genre of music
the banjos is coming and the drums are a
banging let's get the boys together and
have ourselves a hanging oh damn
now I see it
now I see it
hello everyone
I'm Joseph Carmichael
Otis is
was my father
but we are not here today to mourn his
death
but to celebrate his life
we knew Otis as a teacher
a community leader a role model a
husband and a father
now I thought it would be nice to share
something about him you all may not have
known
when my father was younger he was an
actor in Hollywood
going through my dad's things I found
this real
of his work as an actor
I haven't seen it yet but I thought it
would be fun to watch
here with all of you today
[Music]
where are my pies
Rebels where are the pies I put on my
windowsill
wow I don't know Missy Carrabba why
would anyone want to steal one of y'all
delicious blueberry pie
[Music]
hey see to it you shine those shoes up
nice boy yes sir you best be believing I
will I'll shine your shoes blacker than
my mama's booty
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
laughs
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
in 1964 my father marched with Martin
Luther King Jr and Harry Belafonte along
with other renowned civil rights please
[Music]
foreign
do not get me started on the Mexicans
hey
I'll just say it
they hold the goddamn economy together
you know what man damn straight if 12 of
the Mexicans who live in this country
stopped working just 12 percent the USA
was shut down I don't even care who
hears me no they they they they they
work their asses off and they got strong
family values essential immigrants hey
speaking of immigrants
how about them Asians [ __ ] you know what
brother you want to light that fuse then
you better stand back cause I got
something I want to say about those
[ __ ] I got three words for you
it's studious hard-working industrious
damn straight Asians are the highest
income best educated and the fastest
real racial group in the USA plus got
the highest percentage of college
graduates in the country good for them
and maybe this makes me sound racist but
those [ __ ] They're Gonna Save
the country there it is you said you
went and said it I just said I just came
right the [ __ ] out and said it he was in
everyone's mind but I'm the one who said
it hey and you know what while we're at
it I'm gonna break my spawn tip tap
dancing Ransom prancing around the
elephant in the room blacks [ __ ]
blacks
[ __ ] blacks you know what you're done
done dead you opened up the blood Gates
now my friend release the Kraken goddamn
victims the institutionalized racing his
money
yeah
they also came to slavery and the
segregation just to become CEOs
and entrepreneurs and I one of them got
starring president and I mean that's
just true right there that's this
historical fact man can't even argue
that
oh how about the Indians [ __ ] Native
Americans
I don't know if I could get in trouble
these days for saying something like
this but they were here first it may be
unpopular but it's true we we came to
this country and we steamrolled on in
and we genocided them I mean hell we owe
them something there you go
[Music]
I gotta tell you man that's not bad for
a non-alcoholic beer not bad at all all
right I gotta go home take care of my
kids how many of them you got now just
to dive to the 11th oh can't help myself
man that's always what happens when you
volunteer for the earthquake relief in
Haiti
and what your own Luke's gonna do
you know my wife makes two-thirds of
what I make but y'all got the same job
man that's just patently on fire that's
right we're both Librarians you all
right I'm okay
[Music]